[Musique]
nous sommes dans le gâtinais sur une
exploitation céréalière vous allez faire
connaissance avec des jeunes
agriculteurs du canton claire alexandra
adeline pierrick ils nous parlent de
leur quotidien et du salon parisien
parole des jeunes et ça s'appelle c'est
vous qui le dites
combien yat-il d'agriculteurs sur votre
secteur alors je vais vous répondre en
termes d'adhérents haut niveau donc du
gâtinais est nous sommes 24 adhérents
jeunes agriculteurs donc de moins de 35
ans et au niveau du loiret nous sommes
environ 190 adhérents
quelle est leur domaine d'activité
quelle est leur spécialité
donc au niveau des spécialités agricole
sur le secteur donc la principale
production et serial hier mon char lite
est prêt on fait le clap
[Musique]
depuis combien de temps les airs c'est
vous ce métier alors pour le moment je
n'exerce pas encore cette activité je
l'exerçais serait à partir d'octobre
quand je reprendrai l'exploitation à la
fin de l'activité de mon papa beaucoup
d'agriculteurs sont obligés d'avoir deux
métiers pour pouvoir subvenir à leurs
besoins
depuis combien de temps exercé vous ce
métier donc je suis installé depuis 2008
donc voilà je chante i'm la dixième
année je suis installé à mais le roi
donc pas très loin d'ici
donc je suis principalement en
maraîchage biologique et après sur
l'exploitation il ya aussi un élevage de
poules pondeuses des grandes cultures
céréales principalement surfaces
fourragères et 1
un élevage de charolaises je suis
éleveuse d'ânesse donc dans le loiret
dans le gâtinais
depuis combien de temps exercé vous ce
métier et bien cette année ça va faire
neuf ans que je suis installé par les
partenaires film est charlie c'était une
vocation alors une vocation peut-être
pas forcément mais en tout cas une envie
de poursuivre ce qui a été
fait de manière familiale voilà souvent
les exploitations elles sont là depuis
des générations c'était une vocation
oui parce que je suis pas issu de
parents agriculteurs c'est vrai que je
connaissais pas tellement le métier en
fait je n'ai pas grandi et par contre
j'avais envie de m'installer avec des
halles des ânesses plus particulièrement
faire la traite et puis pouvoir
commercialiser les produits en vente
directe êtes vous déjà allé au salon de
l'agriculture qu'en pensez vous c'est
vrai que c'est une très belle vitrine
pour les agriculteurs aujourd'hui ils
ont tant que professionnel on préfère
par exemple aller au salon du matériel
agricole ou au sommet de l'élevage ou
encore innov-agri à outarville qui nous
est beaucoup plus utile c'est mettre à
l'honneur quand même notre notre système
agricole français
après après on est un peu dans le temps
le show quand même j'y suis allé un tank
exposantes
il ya deux ans et cette année je réitère
avec le stand et une ânesse ça coûte
cher de participer ouais c'est destin
qu'on paye
de plusieurs milliers d'euros c'est un
budget vraiment qu'il faut arriver à
répercuter donc c'est pour ça que quand
on a des choses à vendre faut essayer
vraiment de mettre le paquet pour prés
faire connaître notre produit pour que
les gens puissent recommandé derrière et
votre tablette il y perd en mettant ces
cas à chaque vol se met en veille et à
la suppression à la dernière question
c'est pas pratique est